some updates on the developments as the
coronavirus continues to
force the sports world to make
adjustments the nfl
finally moving in the direction of
providing us with some definitive
information although most of it's coming
from the teams teams are one by one in
the process of calling their scouts back
in and their assistant coaches from the
road they have been attending pro day
workouts
and some teams as of early this morning
and yesterday weren't bringing everyone
back but it began with the buccaneers
continued with washington more and more
teams bringing their
scouts and assistant coaches off the
road and also teams starting to take the
position that there will be no visits
before the draft of any prospects to
their facilities every team can bring in
30 players up to 30 players for
pre-draft visits and then there's what
they call the local pro day where a
large crowd of players with geographic
connections to a given team show up all
at the same time those presumably won't
happen either private workouts
likely won't happen that's when teams
send delegations off onto the road to go
see what a guy can do
running a workout that is more
specifically designed to that team's
needs and it happens outside of
everyone's view so those can be
extremely valuable now teams may still
do them
and that's when the league needs to step
in and that's why the league needs to
step in and be the one to tell teams
what can and can't happen because this
is the temptation
the right thing to do
is keep everyone close
no non-essential travel well if some
teams decide to do the right thing and
not have private workouts where they
send four or five people to oklahoma or
alabama or whatever to submit a player
to a private workout
if they say no we're not going to do it
well other teams will and that's how you
get a strategic advantage that's why the
league needs to show the leadership here
this should not be a team by team
decision the scouts coming off the road
should be a league mandate
no pre-draft visits should be a league
mandate no private workouts should be a
league mandate because the temptation is
going to be there for these type a
double positive coaches to try to take
advantage of this vacuum that's going to
be created by having private workouts by
sneaking guys in town by otherwise doing
things
that other teams aren't doing to have an
advantage over those teams so do it for
all or do it for none but the league
needs to be the one that says this is
what we are doing and hopefully it's
moving in that direction hopefully by
the time you see this video the news
will be that the league has told all
teams to stop until then
teams are doing it one by one and
hopefully all teams will do the right
thing scouts and assistant coaches off
the road
no pre-draft visits from prospects and
ultimately
no private workouts conducted in advance
of the draft and yes it limits the
information but you know what maybe
these teams will realize this obsession
with pre-draft information is a waste of
time all that matters is whether or not
a guy can play football and much of that
is gleaned from watching wait for it
videotape of him
playing football at the college level
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports